[Música]
Hola y bienvenidos a Europa hoy el
programa de actualidad Europea de France
24 en español yo soy Esther Herrera caro
desde el parlamento europeo ambroselas
es un placer saludarles en el programa
de hoy hablamos del conflicto entre
Israel y Palestina y concretamente lo
acontecido en los últimos meses con una
escalada de la tensión sin precedentes
que se está produciendo ahora mismo en
la región puede tener la Unión Europea
un papel a la resolución de este
conflicto antes de pasar al debate
escuchamos a nuestra corresponsal en
Jerusalén Yanira Gómez Muñoz que nos
hace un breve resumen de Cuál es la
situación ahora mismo en la región
si las relaciones entre los gobiernos de
Israel y la autoridad Palestina nunca
han sido fáciles hoy están en uno de sus
puntos más bajos desde la firma de los
acuerdos de oslo en 1993 por un lado
Israel tiene El Ejecutivo más radical
cuyo punto Central es la anexión de los
territorios palestinos ocupados y allí
se ha intensificado la violencia y la
represión contra la población Palestina
De hecho son dirigentes
ultranacionalistas y ultrareligiosos
quienes ocupan ministerios como el de
seguridad o finanzas este último a cargo
de parte de la administración de
cisjordania ocupada en frente hay una
autoridad Palestina que no lidera y que
está desprestigiada mahmutabash que no
celebra elecciones desde el 2006 carga
una gran crisis de credibilidad entre
los palestinos y muestra cada vez menos
control del territorio en parte por las
redadas casi diarias del ejército
israelí así han proliferado nuevos
grupos militantes palestinos como los
surgidos en nablus onín con todo
representantes de ambos lados han
protagonizado dos reuniones este año
mediadas por Estados Unidos pero
acordado en pro de calmar las tensiones
fue negado al instante por los propios
ministros israelíes una realidad que
sobre el terreno hace casi imposible una
vía para la paz y para entender un poco
más este complejo conflicto Contamos con
los eurodiputados Jordi solé del grupo
de Los verdes Alianza libre europea
miembro además de la delegación de
relaciones con Israel del parlamento
europeo Gracias Jordi un placer gracias
a vosotros y con César Luna del grupo
social demócrata y miembro
de también de la de exacto de Palestina
de las relaciones con Palestina gracias
a los dos por estar aquí especialmente
en estos últimos días hemos visto un
aumento de las tensiones en la región
Ahora parece que el conflicto se
encuentra en un punto si cabe más
complicado Incluso se habla de una
tercera entifada estamos viendo un punto
y aparte en el conflicto tal y como
ocurrió por ejemplo en la Guerra de los
seis días o del yom kippur César Pues
mira no lo creo yo lo que creo que
estamos viviendo es un momento de crisis
muy grave en Israel
y que buena parte de lo que está pasando
Es una maniobra de distracción del
gobierno
de letanyahu creo que esa es la
explicación es un gobierno que afronta
el particularmente en muchos casos de
corrupción es un gobierno de extrema
derecha y netanyahu ha decidido correr
una cortina o una maniobra de
distracción que no ha colado porque
tiene numerosas protestas dentro de
Israel y una de digamos uno de los
planos principales en esa maniobra de
distracción es de nuevo el conflicto lo
hemos visto lo que ha pasado en la
Explanada de la de la mezquita eso ya lo
hizo Ariel sarón en su momento Entonces
creo que no estamos en un momento de
inflexión en un punto de inflexión
estamos en un punto muy crítico pero que
responde sobre todo a una grave crisis
interna de Israel y particularmente de
su gobierno como digo un gobierno que ha
cometido una reforma judicial que está
siendo protestada por la mayoría de la
sociedad Un gobierno con muchos casos de
corrupción y un gobierno de extrema
derecha
estás de acuerdo sí yo coincido con
César no creo que estemos en un en un
momento digamos
muy diferente al que estamos hace hace
unos meses de hecho esta escalada no es
solo de los últimos días hacer meses que
estamos viendo a muchos actos de
violencia sobre todo en los territorios
ocupados pero la diferencia en estos
momentos es que tenemos en Israel pues
Un gobierno con elementos muy radicales
con partidos Ultra ortodoxos con la
extrema derecha
y un gobierno que no lo olvidemos está
intentando
erosionar de una forma sin precedentes
el estado de derecho y la democracia en
Israel y por eso estás enormes
manifestaciones no de ciudadanos Y
ciudadanas de Israel que le están
diciendo a su gobierno que quieren
preservar un estado democrático y Estado
de derecho por lo tanto yo también estoy
estoy de acuerdo de que la situación
responde en buena parte a una a un
conflicto político interno en Israel
que a su vez responde a una dinámica de
radicalización de la política
israliana israelí yo diría de la última
década no la sociedad también se ha ido
radicalizando por distintas razones no Y
esto tiene una derivada en el conflicto
entre Palestina e Israel pero es un
conflicto que lleva décadas hay una
situación de ocupación de territorios
una situación evidentemente ilegal una
situación de
opresión de discriminación continua
diaria y no vemos una salida a este a
este conflicto Pero además ahora tenemos
el factor añadido de este
conflicto político interno en Israel
también quiero decir una cosa el
gobierno de hoy de nata es un gobierno
radical con elementos de extrema derecha
pero los anteriores gobiernos quizás no
tenían tantos elementos de extrema
derecha pero tampoco hicieron nada para
avanzar hacia la paz y hacia la solución
política al conflicto
justamente ahora mismo la situación que
este gobierno ultraderechista como
comentabas Jordi hace que además se
complique aún más porque el actual
gobierno niega directamente el derecho
de los palestinos a tener su propio
estado pero es que a la vez Hay un
problema también que es que jamás
tampoco reconoce derecho de Israel a
existir ahora mismo
también escuchándoos a los dos parece
que no hay esperanza por ningún lado
está entonces la paz más lejos que nunca
Cesar
Yo creo que la paz está lejos para que
nos vamos a engañar Pero hay un
escenario de la paz y hay un escenario
para la paz eso por lo menos nos da
cierta esperanza y pasa primero por
asumir las dos partes que tiene que
haber dos estados y que se tienen que
reconocer mutuamente y a partir de ahí
yo creo que tienen que hacer esfuerzos
porque es
necesario comprender que tenemos que
volver algunas cosas que se rompieron en
el pasado por ejemplo la situación de
Jerusalén por ejemplo las fronteras del
año 1967 entonces la paz está lejos Sí
pero
hay actores internacionales como la
Unión Europea que queremos la paz y hay
un escenario para la paz Es decir hay
condiciones para la paz lo peor
por ejemplo ahora que estamos ante la
invasión de Ucrania y hay una guerra en
Ucrania no está establecido por ningún
lado Cuáles pueden ser hasta el plan de
paz que ha presentado el gobierno de
Ucrania
el disparate del disparate de Rusia o la
cuestión medio de broma de China sin
embargo aquí con los años acumulados
sabemos Cuáles son las condiciones para
la paz y tiene que ser el reconocimiento
mutuo de los dos estados y es verdad Que
ni la posición y la crisis interna de
Israel ni elementos absolutamente
distorsionadores como es la posición de
jamás en la franja de gaza ayudan pero
yo sí que aporto diciendo que es muy
difícil y que está lejos sí que aporto
Esa visión de esperanza de que habiendo
un escenario para la siempre hay
posibilidades para la paz
en los últimos años la comunidad
internacional ha fracasado en sus
esfuerzos por lograr una paz sustantiva
quizás la vez que hemos estado más cerca
ha sido los años 90 con el acuerdo de
oslo pero es posible que la Unión
Europea ahora pueda tener un mayor papel
tal y como pide el jefe de la diplomacia
europea junto con los Estados árabes
también con Estados Unidos y empujar
hacia la paz Jordi a mí me gustaría que
la Unión Europea yo no diría que tuviera
un mayor papel diría que tuviera un
papel en este conflicto porque hasta
ahora no lo ha tenido hemos sido
ausentes y de hecho este parlamento le
ha pedido al Señor borré y al consejo de
la Unión Europea que lidera una
iniciativa para la paz una iniciativa
Europea de paz en el conflicto entre
Israel y Palestina y creo que
seguramente la Unión Europea no no lo va
a poder hacer sola ni tiene por qué
hacerlo sola no hay otros actores que
también pueden jugar un papel muy muy
importante pero estamos hablando de un
conflicto que dura desde hace ya
muchísimas décadas con una situación
digamos de violación del derecho
internacional de violación
de derechos fundamentales del derecho a
la autodeterminación del pueblo de
Palestina yo también creo que la única
solución
digamos la solución viable y justa es la
solución de los dos estados que se
reconocen entre ellos que conviven
mutuamente El problema es que llevar a
la práctica hoy en día
un estado palestino independiente tal y
como se han ido por ejemplo
desarrollando los asentamientos no la
política de Israel en el área C de los
territorios ocupan ocupados en
cisjordania hace que la viabilidad de un
estado palestino sea una cosa muy muy
complicada por un tema de discontinuidad
territorial No aún así aún así con todas
estas enormes dificultades dificultades
creo que es la solución y la Unión
Europea debe aportar cosas positivas
hacia llegar hasta esta solución una de
las últimas iniciativas que tuvo la
Unión Europea es que en 2013 se ofreció
un paquete de apoyo sin precedentes en
materia económica política y de
seguridad a las dos partes si estas
llegaban a un acuerdo son iniciativas de
este tipo viables y que puedan ayudar a
esta pazo a ninguna de las dos partes
realmente le interesan iniciativas de
este tipo César no yo creo que son muy
importantes y que son incentivos son
estímulos Pero tiene que ser como su
propia palabra su propio nombre indica
tiene que ser a cambio de algo por
ejemplo no puede ser por decirlo todo
que desde 2006 no tengamos elecciones en
Palestina ha habido elecciones en
Palestina eso no puede ser pero no puede
ser lo está diciendo Jordi muy bien que
el estado de Israel esté creando una
especie de Gran prisión una malla que
esté rodeando literalmente rodeando a
los palestinos con los asentamientos
ilegales por tanto tiene que haber
incentivos pero a cambio de que se den
pasos y de que se den pasos políticos
decisivos de verdad elecciones por un
lado desmantelar los asentamientos
ilegales Y por supuesto No construir más
por el otro
a eso nos tiene que llevar esta política
que sí que tiene hacerse que es valiente
pero que tiene que tener
contraprestaciones Jordi muy rápidamente
nos queda muy poco tiempo sí solo Añadir
una una idea no hay unanimidad en el
consejo entre los estados miembros de
cómo aportar cosas positivas a la
solución de este conflicto y creo que
esto nos debilita No el señor burrell
pide una iniciativa europea Pero cuál si
no nos podemos de acuerdo no hay unos
estados que son más Pro israelíes
digamos otros quizás una posición más
más matizada pero yo creo que está claro
que el Punto de partida es el derecho a
existir de los dos estados en paz
reconocimiento mutuo Y a partir de aquí
pues buscar la manera de hacer viable la
existencia del Estado palestino
independiente y ahí hay maneras de
hacerlo incentivos positivos o negativos
no también hay otro tipos de incentivos
que no sería decir si ustedes consiguen
esto nosotros les vamos a ayudar con
aquello Gracias Jordi César
Lamentablemente nos hemos quedado sin
tiempo a ustedes les esperamos en el
próximo programa de Europa hoy Gracias
por ver France 24 en español
[Música]